so
he says uh i want you hold marijuana
that's the hottest thing i
don't know anything about it i've heard
the kids smoking it i said what would he
pay and he said i think they would pay
ten thousand dollars for a trip down
there
i said i'm all for it i said what would
he do if he catch he said nothing
probation he said that thing's almost
legal out here in california
so he introduced me to a fellow and said
you've got an airplane you'd fly down
and i said yeah i'm going down there
fishing all the time anyway they don't
ever bother me
where were you going fishing in mexico
were you really yeah i'd fly down there
on some of my days off morning and i
take the children down there the baby
and uh
so we just had a nice nice life that we
weren't far from mexico and in southern
california
right so uh
i went down and did a load and man i
come back
they give me ten thousand dollars in a
paper bag that was two years paying on
the fire department
take home and i shook it on the bed
and mari put her hand up over her mouth
and oh my i don't believe it
and the baby grabbed 100 bills and
crawling around and we just laughed we
didn't know any money we knew nothing
so we went out to dinner and then put it
in a lock box so
what was that like the first time you
actually flew down to mexico
to pick to to pick up marijuana
i mean it was just picturesque it really
was what i mean what kind of people did
you
did you meet with and what was was it
what you expected
was it shady at all not at all i went to
a place called halapa veracruz
is the capital of the state of
veracruzes up in the mountains
and it was like bible times the people
had like stone basins in the street
and they were scrubbing their the
clothes the women were and i went to
church a catholic church and i walked
around
and and there was the stations of the
cross i'd never seen those
carved all the stations of the cross in
a catholic church
i understand now that they have to
protect them because they're such
valuable art pieces
and i was impressed with that and then i
went out early in the morning
to the airport to load the marijuana and
i had my fireman's badge in my
wallet and so the old guard on judy
he was kind of suspicious of it and i
showed him my fireman's badge and he was
all helpful
so then i taxed it down to the end of
the runway and they met me with a van
and put the
stuff in and uh i was coming back across
and didn't have enough fuel i knew i
wouldn't i'd have to land somewhere so i
landed at a little
a little abandoned strip with a little
stone house at the end of it
and the man that owned marijuana got in
with me so i put him out there and there
was a little
little boy herding goats and his name
was lazarus so
we put the marijuana in a stone house
and i flew into i forgot
one of the cities of mexico and refueled
and came back out and sat there and had
lunch with a little boy then paid back
in there and flew on home
were you worried were you nervous at all
not a bit and you were flying and you
flew down there alone
yes uh-huh but the man that owned the
marijuana flew back with me
okay so we just we didn't have any
trouble with it
and then at what point did he pay you
when you landed back in the u.s
yes they came the next day unpaid and
then the next load they cheated me out
of it
that was all they had so the second load
they didn't have to pay me really yeah
so i took him i i found him and how to
send a detective after him we found him
in new york
and i went up there and stuck a gun in
his ribs and took him down to the wharf
what and he was so nervous he couldn't
even light a cigarette
he thought they're going to kill him of
course i won't hurt him at all but i was
going to scare him in to pay him with my
money so i took his dog
wow his dog was named leslie a beautiful
long-haired
setter and he was so upset about taking
his dog he said take my wife take my
wife i said no that's illegal i'll take
your dog
so i dog napped and i kept the dog and
the children put
bows in her hair because this guy didn't
pay you for the second trip
right so anyhow he never did pay me so
he cost so much heat till our friend out
there said give him his dog
back roger you're gonna bring us all
down how so how did you find it you
hired an
uh a private investigator to like hunt
him down
he went up to a cabin where bill this
guy's name was bill
and where he lived in in the in the
fireplace with some burnt papers and he
looked at it
and there was where the dog was shipped
to vancouver canada and from their
transit ship back to new york
so he he copied the numbers and all down
before
before he touched it and it's
disintegrated and he found out where
right he addressed where bill was
wow he wasn't really a private detector
but he was better than private detector
he was the guy that first introduced me
to these people
oh he was the guy who introduced you
okay one riding across country
right so then what happened did you did
you have an itch to keep doing this
stuff or
oh yeah without that well this is just
easy i went to see a j i wouldn't see
and you had absolutely zero fear of
being caught or getting in any kind of
trouble
no well of course i would flew
just at the treetop level sagebrush
would sometimes be in my
wheel wells and i was afraid of hitting
a power line at night or something more
so than i was
getting caught what was the reason for
flying so low
keep uh keep over radar they had they
had radar
on the hills around there and so they
were trying to catch people they catch
pilots every once in a while
okay what year was this 1973
73 wow so i went to the lawyer and i
said oh yeah
what like what will happen if i get
called with a load of marijuana bringing
in he says
you work on the fire department yeah and
they said yeah
you ever been committed i said never had
a traffic ticket in my life
no no not never a moving violation
he said you'll get probation at the most
you get a year and serve four months
raking leaves on a military base
oh i kind of like that story so i went
and bought me a
bigger airplane a cessna 207. that thing
would carry 1100 pounds and i could make
40 000
in a day how much was i playing
35 000 cessna 207
right wow it's a stretch 206 but
it's the same engine just it's nice 150
miles an hour
carries 1100 pounds and go a thousand
miles so great big old
so uh i started hauling so
i bought me a new cadillac i didn't i
didn't know about all this
about making people look at you and i
had my mother
and my baby sister come out from georgia
and i took him to disneyland
in my new cadillac and mother said what
are you doing boy
i said i'm hauling pot ma she says how
much you're making i said i'm making
forty thousand dollars any day i want to
go down there
he said what did i do if they catch you
so i told her about what the lawyer said
about
four months at the most i said what do
you think ma
she said do you need a co-pilot's son
wow my mother was a sport that's amazing
so did you ever bring a co-pilot with
you or did you always know myself
yeah okay and at this point you're how
old
30 30 years old flying down to mexico
every day making 40 thousand dollars
yeah we got word to do about once a week
and then you had six months or something
there was no pot
okay so you had to you had to work are
you still dealing with the guy who you
had to hunt down
and steal his dog i just i just got in
touch with him a few weeks ago he
he got in touch with me on facebook i
mean i mean at this point when you're
when you're routinely flying to mexico
and back are you still dealing with the
same guy
no i i we we
separate waited a little bit ways okay
yeah but no hard feelings i think he
just didn't want to get very
involved in it so you found somebody
else you could do business with well i
didn't even
i didn't have anybody i just did it
myself so
what did you do you just flew down to
the same location and said hey who's got
pot well he had it this guy joaquin is a
little a little river come there just
north of mazatlan in the state of
sinaloa
and it came through a cliff in the
rivers and had a like a waterfall
and then there was a poor poor village
called peachylinky
starving donkeys looked like starving
people
and that on the bend of the river in the
sand was a 900 foot runway
if you could call it a runway you rudded
yeah it's real
short but the tesla 207 would make it so
but it wouldn't take off with a load
so this young because the runway was too
short it's too heavy you need longer
you're right so i would
i would take enough fuel down with me
and mari and i would go to the grocery
store and get
little goodies and apples and toys for
the children and i'd pass out the boxes
of those and they just loved them
so every day more and more children were
showing up for that runway
they had heard of the american santa
claus that was coming
the american santa claus
i